hail to the king baby according to a new
report a remake of jute Nukem 3d will be
announced next week I'm Lucy and welcome
to your unless it's better than jute
Nukem Forever GameSpot news update the
source of the rumor is a reddit post but
its veracity has been strengthened by
the appearance of a new jute newcombe
website featuring a countdown clock
according to the reddit user Tesla 55
who sites somebody that has leaked the
information to him the game is called
Duke Nukem 3d World Tour and is being
developed by nerve software a studio
founded by an ex edge software developer
nerf has previously contributed to the
development of Call of Duty advanced
warfare call of duty black ops 3 and the
doom 2 remake for Xbox Live the likud
describes world tour as a remix of gem
Nukem 3d that will have a lot of new
slash original content added it will
also supposedly feature both online
co-op and deathmatch gameplay modes but
the leaker isn't a hundred percent sure
on this of course as compelling as the
screenshots and countdown website are
they're also very vey Keable given that
Jude Newcomb's 20th anniversary is
approaching it would be the perfect
timing for hoax or for an announcement
so we've contacted gearbox for a
statement in July 2015 a gearbox
software founder Randy Pitchford said
that the studio had started production
on an all-new head-turning duke nukem
game so would you play Duke Nukem 3d
again or did forever burn you too much
let me know in the comments below or
come find me on Twitter I met Lucy James
games for gaming news keep it GameSpot